you're coming home we wanna hardly be
happy this is where our house used to be
before the genocide nothing is left of
it now the killer's bent it all down
after looting it eric musii was just
three months old when his parents and
four siblings were killed four Hutu
militias he's a survivor of the 1994
genocide in Ronda the fastest of the
20th century during which close to a
million run dance mostly Tutsi were
wiped out in just 100 days Eric was too
young to remember his family dying but
he says he will never forget the day his
son told him what happened she carried
me on her back during the genocide right
up until the killing stopped she told me
how horrific it was she witnessed it all
the rain was pouring down on us those
were hard times for many days would flee
from the Calais and while we were
fleeing we would jump over dead bodies I
will be seen
Eric's dark family history is one shared
by many his relatives like countless
persecuted Tutsi across the country had
sought refuge in a church when they were
killed a church just like this one in
Yamata for an estimated 50,000 people
died during the genocide
today the site stands is one of rundas
most poignant memorials a disturbing
reminder of what happened and physical
evidence of crimes that should never be
forgotten you can't imagine how it feels
like growing up knowing that you're all
alone with no parents and no siblings
while other children your age have them
eric says his generations identity is
deeply entrenched in the trauma of 1994
it's not only survivors who lost their
families who are still processing the
past but also children of perpetrators
who participated in the killings like
every name is zero
yeah I would say asanga our new young
away it's very hard to find yourself all
alone either because your family members
were killed for being too c4 as in my
case with parents who are in prison
because they were convicted of
participating in the genocide as
children we had to take on a lot of
responsibility from a young age the
genocide could cast a long dark shadow
over the lives of future generations yet
a belief in the power of reconciliation
is ushering a new chapter in Rhonda's
history as the youth we have to live in
a way that brings us together to keep
our country moving forward what would
you what was the youth are the future of
the country
totally morality